i'll play d4  earlier i was going to play a london and  then forgot  but here's my redemption  i don't think we've had a london the  stream  what's london time  knight f3  take back oh take back's disabled  it's a london gambit  oh no  okay  novelty line  i feel like we're already in a position  that's never been reached before  it's kind of cool too  because i'm getting initiative and it  takes i take with knight now i control  these squares surprise prepare this  i mean i could be normal and take on d4  or i can be abnormal  and provoke on poisson and then take on  or lose a bishop  am i doing  i wasn't lying earlier when i said i'm  tired  don't know my bishop  check me okay  i got away with that one  oh so much happened in those 12 moves  i played the london i mouse slipped in  the opening i invented a new cool gambit  i pinned a knight i blundered the bishop  i developed my queen i took a knight i  hung a bishop and then i made it